>>> IN MY LIFE, I'VE LIVED IN
SOME OF THE HARDEST
NEIGHBORHOODS IN AMERICA.
COMPTON, SPANISH-HARLEM,
BENSTUY.
THIS IS THE UPPER EAST SIDE.
IT'S THE UES WHERE THE PLAYERS
PLAY.
NOW I'M MOVIN' ON UP LIKE THE
JEFFERSON SHOW.
GOT THAT NOBODY PEED IN HERE
SUBWAY SMELL.
♪ AIN'T NO DRAMA
THE CAR'S STRICTLY MELLOW
JUST SOME WORKING FOLKS
AND THEIR KIDS WITH A CELLO ♪
♪ SOME THINK IT'S SLEEZY
WELL [ BLEEP ] THE HATERS
YOUR TRAIN'S GOT STAIRS
WE GOT ESCALATORS ♪
♪ THIS AIN'T HARLEM YA'LL
I GOT SCENES FOR DAYS
AND A CAB OUTSIDE
THAT COMES RIGHT AWAY ♪
♪ I ORDER WHERE I WANT
YA'LL CAN'T STOP ME
2:00 IN THE MORNING BRING ME
SALMON AND BROCCOLI ♪
♪ THINK THERE AIN'T NO BLACK
FOLKS YOU MISTAKEN THERE'S
NANNIES AND NURSES AND A DOORMAN
WHOSE JAMAICAN ♪
♪ THOUGHT THAT DEAD NOW I'M A
LADY FROM COMPTON
INLINE FOR FRESH BREAD ♪
♪♪♪
>> MAN, EVERYBODY'S BALLIN' ON
THE UPPER EAST SIDE.
PEOPLE FROM ALL OVER THE WORLD
COME TO LIVE THE UES LIFE.
LIKE THE GERMAN DUDE WHO BAKES
MY BREAD HIT HIM UP ONE TIME ♪
♪ IT'S THE UES
AND I KNOW WHAT YOU WANT
GOT A LINE OUT THE DOOR
FOR $12 CROISSANT ♪
♪ FIVE STARS ON YELP
YEAH, YOU KNOW THE SITCH
I BAKE A CHERRY STREUDEL
MAKE ZAGA MY BITCH ♪
♪ MY FATHER BAKED BREAD
AND MY FATHER'S FATHER
YOU GET BREAD SOMEWHERE ELSE
DON'T EVEN BOTHER ♪
♪ LADIES GOT THE HOOKUP
JUST ASK FOR MIKA
I'LL TAKE HER TO HEAVEN
BEFORE YOU HAD YOUR -- ♪
>> YEAH, THAT'S THAT EAST SIDE
LIFE.
YO, YOU THINK WEST SIDE IS
POPPIN?
COME OVER TO UES WHERE IT'S ALL
GOIN' ON.
♪ WE COULD HIT THE MET GALA
STAY HOME WITH MY CATS
GO TO CAFÉ CARLYLE
OR STAY HOME WITH MY CAT ♪
♪ OR STAY HOME WITH MY CAT
HOME WITH MY CAT
HOME WITH MY CAT ♪
♪ IT'S GOING TO BE A PARTY
WHEN I'M HOME WITH MY CAT
'CAUSE I GOT A NETFLIX
AND I GOT A WARM CAT ♪
♪ GOT A WARM CAT
GOT A WARM CAT
I GOT A COZY BLANKET
AND I GOT A WARM CAT ♪
♪ ITS THE UES
WHERE THE PLAYERS PLAY
WE GOT NAIL SALONS
AND DINERS FOR DAYS ♪
♪ I USED TO BE BASIC
BUT THAT WAS LONG AGO
NOW I'M MOVING ON UP
LIKE THE JEFFERSON SHOW ♪
>> THERE IT IS.
UES FOR LIFE, SON.
WE CAN'T GO BACK.
THEY SAY, LESLIE, YOU FORGOT
WHERE YOU CAME FROM.
BITCH, I LIVE HERE, BECAUSE I
REMEMBER WHERE I CAME FROM.
UPPER EAST SIDE.